new tonight heartbreaking case of animal
neglect a young pit bull brought back to
the animal foundation just one year
after being adopted but weighing half of
what he originally weighed as victoria
saha reports a local rescue group
stepped in when the owner tried
returning the dog
zion a three-year-old pitbull mix has
gained the love of everyone at the anima
hospital but his eyes and malnourished
body show us the lack of love and care
he received ever since walking out of
the animal foundation one year ago this
rather
tall person
with a very sickly looking dog kelly
winder is a dog rescuer he happened to
be at the animal foundation this past
weekend when zion and his owner showed
up i just casually asked him
is that a found dog he said no i'm
returning him he was in horrible shape
for a return winder tells us this is
when the owner was getting
confrontational not wanting to sign any
surrender papers all he wanted to do was
walk in there
with as little effort as possible
drop him
and leave fearing for zion's future
winder immediately stepped in to take
responsibility of zion
that's what it was like a year ago not
only does it look like zion was starved
but doctors say that the sores on his
body are a clear indicator that he was
forced to lay on the concrete outside
for months i wanted to cry zion is now
under the care of vegas pet rescue
project the animal foundation tells us
they don't do reference checks but make
sure they don't give animals to people
who have any animal abuse charges in
their system they choose let's give them
the benefit of the doubt
i'm not sure what goes on in their minds
victoria zaha live local now